[Music]
in living a lie news oh you liar
living a lie submitted by coffee shop
Vietnamese coffee shop I think it means
the weed store oh oh yeah coffee shops
in Amsterdam sells weed and cafe sells
coffee that's what I'm trying to say cuz
they're not allowed to legally sell or
we look at vertical yeah technically in
Europe it's only a cafe I think the term
coffee shop is actually the weird term a
man comes forward with an extraordinary
secret about his teaching career what's
his secret he doesn't know how to read
he's been copying from another teacher
the whole time down jail how'd you guess
it
oh really if you just teach him and you
Mathis he went throughout his entire
life not knowing how to read obviously
what was he teaching he dyslexic
severely dyslexic damn you're killing it
she's working it to me what does he
teach [ __ ] Otto I'll start from the
beginning which arts character what it
was just like PE it's like oh yeah
alright so this man his name is John
Kenney spell he knew how to write his
name ok ok so he grew up in New Mexico
in the 40s and 50s so this is a long
time ago he was a high school teacher
for 17 years from 1961 to 1978 but he
passed his teaching test that's probably
leaning it back then yeah so he actually
tells his entire story in the article if
you guys want to know the full details
you can try boo because it's uh I'm
gonna just give you the overview ok
it's actually pretty interesting cuz he
just talks about how he would have to
copy people all the time like he had
friends to help him like answer
questions on the test like he even sat
by a window in high school and like
passed his tests were too
friends like you did a lot he treated
the entire time yeah just to be a
teacher the funny thing is he cheated
but he went back to school yeah exactly
so he lied down I've been like getting
away with that this whole time but
somehow I ended up landing here it was
because it was a teacher shortage around
that time so that was the best is an
easy job yeah and then he had also
gotten a college degree already because
I keep cheated his way though to give me
a soldier it's a good friends dude best
but no one ever or he never he says like
he never told anyone he couldn't read it
was like his heavily guarded secret so
I'm not sure how he would convince these
people to like yeah I just didn't study
maybe that I mean you pay you what this
proves that our education [ __ ] sucks
cuz he should have never passed so in
second grade when they were learning how
to read because of the fact that
especially back then they were just so
more relaxed they would just slump them
to the next grade like you're a smart
kid you'll get it event they did that
[ __ ] at my school so he would just go on
to the next grade in the next period on
x-rayed by the time you got to fifth
grade he gave up trying to read he was
like you know what this is just the way
my life is gonna be yeah by eighth grade
he realized that he did have athletic
and math skills also he had great social
skills so that's how you know he made
friends how do you know you have good
athletics if you can't read the score
war I made five points yeah like you do
numbers and stuff if you spell out boobs
on the calculator could he read it yeah
cuz those are numbers like eighty
thousand and eighty-five [ __ ] him up for
life yeah so like he beard out how to
get his friends who were mostly girls to
do this home apartment
I like kitty okay this is in high school
oh yeah
[ __ ] stereotype you like a Brock
Lesnar seems Biff he does look like the
stereotypical jock
they make movies about it yeah that
[ __ ] no wonder he fits the
stereotype too like he can't read just
athletic yeah me no in high school
you're still reading at a second grade
level read and like I said he cheated
his way through high school and college
he even join a fraternity that kept
copies of old exams so he could cheat
that way that's all of them that never
change yeah they really do that no you
haven't Cole they still do that that's
great you pay for something or think you
know I mean you pay to be in a frat yeah
if they just give it to you like what
did you lose it oh they probably mean
it's Yeezy nowadays there's just whole
entire websites that dude essays and all
that and you just have to pay I wish I
had that knee pain I actually had a
[ __ ] work through all this [ __ ]
encyclopedia for sure yeah that was even
this one instance where a friend of it
that guy from the window that I
mentioned earlier
John was helping that guy get a girl for
the dance and that's why the guy was
like our Adam down okay so he was very
like he used his strengths of being able
to like network you have a particle
about this which is kind as a politician
at one point he even broke into a
professor's office and stole copies of a
test because that's how desperate she
was at long like he just bullies he kept
trying yeah my ass just never tried yeah
no not even gonna do it yeah he always
had in his mind because his parents said
you live a good life when you have an
education so he that just like captain
he was desperate for it yeah so what
does he teach this happened because
someone exposed him or he decided you
know what I can't live like this anymore
I'm gonna go learn how to read no yeah
he even got married his wife didn't know
he had kids until his Wow water until he
was reading to his daughter one night
and like he he was just making up the
stories she was like you don't read like
mommy and then his wife overheard
because previous to that he did open up
to her he was like I can't read and she
laughed it off she probably thought like
oh you know it was a joke yeah so mean
so then not until that moment where he
was reading to his daughter that's why
his wife found out like oh my gosh he
really can't read so he taught social
studies oh yeah that's one of the
useless ones yeah well he said that he
taught a lot of different things he
taught he was an athletics coach he
taught social studies he studies is just
history yeah history but all the coaches
taught social studies he also cannot
bells my favorite one oh you know what
he can have them popcorn read so he can
hear it himself and he learns on his own
too he also taught typing because he
could copy type he didn't know he was
old typing like he just didn't know how
like what it was clever dude was he
copying like this they need they taught
them how to tie it properly
I wonder what life is like like he goes
that's why he doesn't know what any of
the signs say like I'll turn on spoon
Street like which ones that one you like
it what about directions I never used a
coupon anything doesn't even know like
oh he knows numbers and the coupon has a
picture oh yeah yes I kind of know what
that feels like because I can't read
Japanese but I could speak it so I when
I walk around I just see the letters I
go just art yeah so eventually he quit
teaching and he went on to be a real
estate developer he was successful at
this for ten years until his business
struggled when he was finally 48 years
old that's when he saw a commercial
about adult literacy issues and that's
when he realized that he wasn't alone
that there are other adults out there
that don't don't know how to read so he
went to his local library to find to get
help with that program and he finally
began to learn did he see me whether at
the gathering so he's saying that
Barbara Bush inspired him to ask for
help and finally learned to Rica's she's
starting this program
that's dope and then so it took him
about seven years to read at an adult
level so finally no oh good for him so
here's some more photos of them so we
saw that one boys Brock Lesnar looking
dude is a good-looking dude
Robocop the robotic jocks in the square
haircut I know you met Barbara Bush oh
he's adorable and then like they oh nice
coat I want that coat why do I do
they're real no why do they look like
wax museum they do they look fake people
and they didn't know who's taking the
picture and wasn't gonna vote it's a
candid photo but why's everyone smiles I
worry about where the camera was again
he looks like he curry I love him adopt
me
yeah wait so his daughter when she was a
baby that girl right there
mm-hmm he hates her he's like cuz of you
you this is the [ __ ] story go to
sleep so now he you don't that's cuz
mama reads [ __ ] really you a teacher
I know he got away with it that whole
time that's crazy that's so funny cuz he
goes into the profession where you
absolutely need that yeah yeah but that
just goes to show you you absolutely
don't yeah thank you til you make it do
all these back then I don't think you
can fake it now or maybe can you I don't
know it's wrong if I was like if I got
anxiety from from in a certain
environment I wouldn't want to go back
he didn't literally you know like how
you always teach children cheaters never
prosper his daughter just be like well
good alright I don't know who said that
because cheaters do prosper it's just
when you get caught bad cheaters never
smart cheaters you covering it up I mean
really smart people always looking for
loopholes always trying to hack [ __ ]
whatever that's cheating essentially
right true so businessman Wall Street
politics they all cross work yeah oh
yeah the the leaders of them maybe
they're the ones telling us yeah I want
to cheat on everything I think the real
thing is cheap but don't get caught
that's a great lesson for this way yeah
go home with that one but oh here's the
thing you can cheat but don't cheat
yourself
see that's my rule don't cheat yourself
cuz like it's like it's like you know
let's say you have to do ten push-ups
right but if you're half-assing the
push-ups you're only cheating north your
seat other people yeah Sheik the [ __ ]
system she the scores all those things
are fine just don't cheat your
shelf have honor now so John was saying
that at first he was really embarrassed
about his story because he went
throughout like pretty much his whole
life without telling anyone that he
couldn't read and it the fact that he
was a teacher in his community too so
not until his tutor convinced him like
you should really share your story this
will inspire many people and then that's
what led him to meeting Ferber Bush see
he prosper cheated all his life and he
got to meet the president yes this is a
Sun reader oh I cried and cried after I
started learning to read there was a lot
of pain and a lot of frustration but it
filled a big hole in my soul adults who
can't read are suspended in their
childhoods emotionally psychologically
academically spiritually we haven't
grown up yet
it wasn't easy but once I made up my
mind I was going to tell the story I
told it all across America I spoke to
anybody that would listen I guarded this
secret for decades and then I blasted it
to the world
he has since written two books and
became a spokesman for literacy programs
and he also runs his own foundation that
helps people learn to read because
people of that time were so [ __ ] dumb
that they didn't know that things like
this exist
so people felt so like alone taking your
hardships and turning into something
that helps other people's aweso for him
enough all these geezers are gonna be
like I can't read - I'm so proud of you
Biff
[Music]